Вже зовсім скоро за натискання кнопки для голосування замість колеги
депутати можуть заплатити з власної кишені - від 50 до 85 тисяч гривень.
Верховна Рада підтримала у першому читанні законопроект,
який посилює відповідальність за так зване "кнопкодавство".
Безперечно, кримінальна відповідальність ніколи не була панацеєю від злочинів,
але все одно наявність її - це є той важливий фактор,
який буде стримувати кожного в бажанні нестримно проголосувати за іншого.
Ми зібралися тут для того, щоб представляти волю українського народу
і нести за це персональну відповідальність.
Неособисте голосування давно стало традицією українського парламентаризму.
Цим грішили депутати всіх скликань.
За 12 років роботи у Верховній Раді Антон Яценко тиснув кнопку колег 129 разів.
Каже, робив це на благо країни.
Йдуть нормальні закони, наприклад, збільшення на дитячу онкологію.
Треба його приймати чи не треба?
Колеги кажуть: ми не проти, щоб за нас проголосували, але нас в залі немає.
Тому треба знаходити вихід з ситуації. І тому люди рятували ситуацію. А як? І не один я, слава Богу.
Боротьба з "кнопкодавством" та прогулами народних обранців
були виборчими обіцянками президента Володимира Зеленського.
Попри це двоє депутатів "Слуги народу" вдалися до "кнопкодавства"
вже у перший тиждень роботи нової Ради.
За свої дії вони публічно вибачилися.
Аби спокутувати провину, місячну зарплатню витратили на благодійність.
Я в тому турборежимі дуже переживав,
я така емоційна людина і дуже справедлива в тому плані, що дуже за благе діло переживаю.
Так все сталося, що воно автоматично все здійснилося.
Я потім цю помилку усвідомив.
Громадський рух "Чесно" фіксує випадки неособистого голосування
протягом останніх восьми років.
Порушення активісти знімають на відео,
надають їм розголосу і навіть складають рейтинги злісних "кнопокодавів".
До прикладу, депутатам вдавалося проголосувати за сімох колег протягом 10 секунд,
які відводяться для волевиявлення.
Сьогоднішній законопроект у "Чесно" не вважать панацеєю,
адже процедура покарання депутатів надто складна.
І її втілення може затягнутися на місяці.
На думку активістів, сенсорна кнопка в системі Рада була би в рази ефективнішою.
Однак через 10 років після встановлення вони так і не запрацювали.
Про неї просто забули, по-перше.
А по-друге, зрозуміло, що так в умовах там постійної політичної цієї нестабільності,
турбулентності, коли коаліція є сьогодні, завтра її вже немає.
А закони ухвалювати треба і відповідно зрозуміло стає, що якщо от зараз включити сенсорну кнопку,
то фактично це ставить хрест на тому, що можливо будуть просто ухвалюватись закони.
Тим часом подібна, але новіша система для персонального голосування депутатів
вже декілька років успішно працює в Київраді.
За цей час жодного випадку кнопкодавства там не зафіксували.
Нинішнє ж керівництво Верховної Ради вважає,
що спершу необхідно провести технічну експертизу сенсорної системи.
Водночас додаткового оснащення потребуватиме зала Верховної Ради
і після прийняття закону про кнопкодавство Руслана Стефанчука.
Адже фіксувати випадки неособистого голосування муситиме апарат Верховної Ради.
Відеозапис "кнопкодавства" разом зі стенограмою і протоколом засідання
направлятимуть до Державного бюро розслідувань.
І якщо суд визнає провину законотворців,
ті понесуть кримінальну відповідальність і заплатять штраф.
Замість того, щоб вирішити технічне питання й унеможливити взагалі голосування депутатів,
ми придумуємо, як ми будемо когось карати,
ідучи через дві інстанції судів,
щоб стягти з нього там 50 тисяч гривень за те, що він голосував кнопкодавством.
Має сенс в людини забирати мандат,
тобто фактично лишати його того, чим депутат має користуватися.
За кнопкодавство, ймовірно, таки позбавлятимуть мандату.
Але це станеться після того, як Конституційний суд розгляне,
а депутати підтримають зміни до Основного закону України,
які раніше ініціював Володимир Зеленський.
Вони передбачають виключення з депутатських лав за неперсональне голосування
та невідвідування засідань Верховної Ради.
А поки депутати вправно голосують кожен за себе,
але дослухаючись до підказок спікера Дмитра Разумкова…